and what happens with a lot of people is
as they get older and they accumulate
pain and hurts from broken relationships
is they don't want to be vulnerable
anymore because they don't want to have
to go through that
but that means that the person that
broke your heart that made you
vulnerable has one has defeated you has
made you turn into something that you
don't want to become
so you have to be able to feel that you
can be vulnerable right and if you're a
seducer trying to seduce someone
revealing to that other person that you
have fallen under their spell
is almost the most seductive thing you
can do
because it's deeply deeply exciting to
feel that that other person is charmed
by us
[Music]
welcome to episode 121 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with
best-selling author robert greene
it was intense
he walked me through the nine seduction
types in one of his books and gave
examples of each told me which one i was
and which one he was
it was fun he spoke about common
manipulation techniques how using his
laws of power aren't always manipulative
the ruthless power structures in
hollywood tips on being vulnerable and
his new book the daily laws robert
greene's an american author known for
his books on strategy power and
seduction he has written six
international bestsellers including the
48 laws of power the art of seduction
the 33 strategies of war the 50th law
mastery and the laws of human nature
like i mentioned his newest book is the
daily laws this was a really fun episode
if you want to learn how to communicate
with people effectively and seductively
check out his work if you like this
content be sure to hit subscribe i hope
you enjoy this episode
robert greene welcome to my podcast well
thank you for having me so much mikayla
i really appreciate it
i'm very excited for this episode i'm a
huge fan of your books so this should be
good i'm a huge fan of your father his
books and his overall intelligence so
please say hello to him for me i will we
should get you guys together i will work
on that in the future that would be a
fun conversation so
we'll do that we'll do that at some
point uh before we get started could you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
well um i'm basically just a writer i
don't really do anything else
i have a seventh book that is coming out
my first book is the most famous it's
the 48 laws of power
i've also written the art of seduction
the 33 strategies of war
i did a book that i co-authored with the
rapper 50 cent
called the 50th law
i did mastery the laws of human nature
which came out a few years ago
and
my new book the daily laws which will be
out in a couple of weeks
and i'm currently working on my eighth
book right now
they kind of tend to center on subjects
like power and strategy
and mastering your own career and and
human behavior i have i had to choose a
common theme and that's about all i do
well eight books is quite a lot so that
sounds like full-time work
yeah
how did you get started on writing about
the topic of power what makes you
knowledgeable about power
well i don't really have a degree it's
not anything i could say oh i graduated
from princeton with a degree and those
are overrated anyway in my opinion yeah
well right i don't know anything like
that basically what happened was in my
20s and 30s i sort of knew that i wanted
to be a writer but i couldn't quite
figure out what i wanted to write
so i tried my hand at all these
different jobs i worked in journalism i
did cons i lived in europe for many
years i worked in a hotel as a
receptionist tour guide in ireland a
teacher of english in spain i worked in
a detective agency here in los angeles
you name it i did it and and then i
worked in hollywood prior to writing my
first book through all of these
experiences
i observed every manner of huma of
manipulation and power game that was
going on from all different kinds of
bosses and all different kinds of
endeavors
and i'm somebody who kind of likes
authenticity and realness in people
the fact that um
that we're sort of ashamed of our own
nature we're ashamed that we're this
animal that actually has desires for
power that has ambitions
that has a dark side has always
disturbed me
and so based on my experiences and based
on all i had learned throughout my years
of wandering through my studies in
college the books that i read
i wrote the 48 laws of power now i can't
say it came from anything else except my
own experience and my own brain
but i think the success it has has shown
that it's
somehow has resonated with the truth
with so many people
okay
so from your experience in hollywood
what was the type of manipulation
that you saw that was mainly used there
well
every every single form because it's a
place in a place where people pretend to
be
so liberal so woke so progressive
but really what motivates a lot of their
behavior is just naked power
they want to have
admiration they want to be recognized
and they want to be respected as someone
who has a position of power in the
pecking order in hollywood right and so
they don't they don't reveal that it's
things that i observed going on behind
the scenes that revealed to me all of
these manipulative games that were going
on
so so many of the laws of power were
kind of based on things i observed
such as conceal your intentions such as
get others to do the work but always
take the credit
on and on and on crush even crush your
enemy totally i observed all of those in
my experiences in hollywood because
people are motivated to disguise all of
their maneuvers you know you don't want
to be seen as somebody who's later
revealed to be a harvey weinstein you
want to project
this liberal magnanimous image
and so it's like something you don't
really ever talk about or see
but i saw from first-hand experience and
that's what i wrote about i mean i could
tell you specific stories i don't know
if you're interested in that or not i'm
interested
i'm definitely interested
well the story that kind of sticks out
mainly in my mind
was i was working for a director i'm not
going to say his name
um
and basically he had written a
screenplay
um
and he he was just sort of starting out
as a director he'd written a screenplay
and he knew
that if he tried to be the director
himself
people would think he was being too
ambitious he was going to write and just
direct it and all of that
so what he did was instead
working with the producer he made a
point of hiring this young man who i
believe at the time was in his late 20s
who was just starting out who had had
written a screenplay and had directed
one film and he hired him knowing full
well that it was above his head and that
he was more than likely going to fail
you know and he kind of set it up so the
guy would fail he wasn't always there to
help him with certain meetings and he
wasn't helping him working on the script
etc and so lo and behold two days into
production the guy was messing up left
right and center and the producer fired
him
and now the man that i was working for
was able to come and say look i can
rescue this project let me be let me
direct it and he concealed his
intentions completely that nobody had
suspected that he was really kind of
behind all of this that he was sort of
maneuvering it in that direction and
then it made him look like he was the
rescuing angel as opposed to this
devious machiavellian person who had set
it all up
that's creepy that sounds like an
exhausting way to live
keeping track of
all the stories that you're telling
people that sounds like a lot of work
you mean for me personally
well no i meant for the guy who had
manipulated this person into failing and
then taken
credit for being the savior
yeah it didn't you know it
in the end what bothered me most of all
about it because you know i can't help
but say that i'm a little bit admiring
people who have the guts to pull
something like that off but on the other
hand
he basically ruined this guy's career
because it was such a failure that it
really hurt his reputation i know i
followed it up immediately afterwards
and he had gone through he hadn't
written or directed anything since he
may have somehow
revived his career i'm not sure but it
really really hurt his reputation and so
that was the thing that that really
really bothered me in the end
okay well it sounds like something that
should bother you
yeah
yeah that's interesting i feel like
trying to weave those stories
and manipulate situations like that
i feel like it's actually more difficult
just to do things honestly
what do you mean by that
well i mean
i mean the way he went about it
hiring somebody and then having them
fail and then saving it i feel like
that's actually the easy way out
compared to
doing what's honest which is hey i wrote
this screenplay and i want to direct it
and then fighting that way which
probably makes your life more pleasant
in the long run
rather than having to manipulate
everybody is a lot of hollywood like
that with people just playing these
games
well you know it's my own personal
experience i saw that up front i can't
say that it's anecdotal but i've worked
i've now been working with people in
hollywood who are trying to produce
some of my own books for film and
television and i consult with a lot of
directors and actors and people in the
business
and it's a nat and then they all they
all have stories to tell me about things
that are even worse than what i've told
you
so i do believe it's it's pretty you
know what spread out there
and even though things are getting
better in some ways they're trying to
diversify hollywood
you know with more women and morbid
ethnicities etc
still that all kind of power dynamic is
there because it's an industry it's
always been like that going back to the
earliest days in the 1920s
and so i don't think that's ever really
going to change
there is one industry i can tell you
that's even worse than hollywood which
is i've learned through my you know
exposure to rappers etc is the music
industry the things that go on the music
industry make hollywood look like
kindergarten but
okay
okay and is that is that mostly like
relationships between men and women
in the music industry
no it's between like record producers
and artists and managers etc
you know where it's a very very
exploitative environment where
um
you know people that you never really
know where the money is coming from how
many albums you've sold
particularly now with the um with so
many things being streamed there's a lot
of deception going on a lot of funny
marketing
uh sorry funny accounting going on to
hide the revenue streams and then people
who are fresh who come into the business
early on they sign contracts without
realizing they're signing away all the
ownership to their work
you know it was it was 50 cent who kind
of revealed a lot of this to me and he
said
you know he grew up on the streets of
southside queens dealing crack seeing
people murdered dealing with hardcore
stuff day in and day out and he said
nothing had ever prepared me for the
[ __ ] i saw in the music business it was
it was worth because at least on the
streets people were direct you kind of
more or less knew where they were coming
from but he never knew where these
people were coming from and it was very
disorienting
i wonder if that's going to change
rather dramatically like things are
changing so much with people being able
to grow social media profiles and have
followers on youtube i know a couple of
artists that haven't signed with anyone
because they're like
why i already have you know two million
followers on youtube the marketing
aspect is kind of gone i'm wondering if
that'll change and then these contracts
that are like what are they called
the ones that you like you said you sign
away everything like that's got to start
fading away even just book publishers i
find
that take a a large percentage because
they're offering marketing services well
a lot of people don't need marketing
services anymore if they can get on
podcasts or yeah
that's true it's very true and there's a
kind of democratization going on but the
only thing that's the film business is
different i think than those other
examples because
to make a film and marketed you really
really are dependent on the hollywood
power structure you could make your film
cheap on an
iphone for instance which people do
nowadays and film it but you're not
going to be able to get a theatrical
release you're not going to be able to
to get it streaming on netflix etc so
you are very much dependent on the old
power structures there so that kind of
democratization that's very positive
that's going on with the internet
it's happening a little bit in hollywood
but i don't think it's i think it's
going to reach the limit
yeah i wouldn't be surprised um for for
the 48 laws of power why did you choose
48
you probably get that question
constantly
i get that question um
well
i didn't really choose 48 the process
was kind of weird i i don't usually like
to reveal
you know how the sausage is actually
made but i guess i'll go ahead and tell
you
um
you know i started out
researching all of the great power of
people and influencers throughout
history and all cultures and all the
power games that were that that were
kind of
the most
sexiest most interesting
and out of that i kind of derived these
patterns of
of behavior that transcended time and
culture and i had 72 of these patterns
originally
which were which would were to be loss
of power and slowly i started
eliminating them because these this
didn't seem strong enough i started
combining them getting rid of them and i
ended up with 52 if you can believe it
or not
and publishers said
you know 52 it doesn't sound good and
it's also sounds a little pat it sounds
like you meant it to be 52 weeks of the
year or 52 cards in a deck we preferred
the number 48
and
so i go well
you know what am i going to say
but then i thought about it because i
don't like to be too rigid and too close
and stubborn i thought
it's true 48 laws sounds a lot better
than 52. it looks better it's a very
powerful number so i'm going to do what
they say but i'm going to take the four
laws that are kind of extra
and i'm going to combine them
into other laws and create these kind of
double laws with two sides to them and
bring it down to 48. so i don't usually
like try to reveal that but i guess
you you lured it out of me somehow but
that's sort of wide ended up with 48.
okay well clearly that paid off
something worked
yeah well you know things like numbers
and colors they have a kind of a primal
effect on us and you can't ignore this
sort of
nonverbal primitive side of our of our
nature
and so
you know like the color red as people
know on on who design like facebook
you know as a button has this certain
effect where it's black as this effect
the number 48 i for some reason kind of
has this sort of
it just seems definitive whereas if it
were 47
that wouldn't have that feeling or 49 or
50 sounds like too obvious but man that
48 it's like a sweet spot you know
what am i gonna do
that is strange but very true
so are any are any of these laws of
power
like honest or are they all kind of
types of manipulation
no
i'd say more than half are honest and
more than half are kind of common sense
and relatively positive
you know so
interaction with boldness is not an evil
law it means when you start something if
you show that you are bold and decisive
people are attracted to that i talk
about play a perfect courtier
the world that we live in every kind of
time there's a power structure it's like
a court surrounding a king and you have
to be charming and you have to be polite
and you have to be gracious in this
court so there's nothing kind of i mean
you might find that a little devious but
it's mostly about being polite
and understanding other people and kind
of playing understanding the culture
that you're in
there's plenty of there's a law called
work on the hearts and minds of others
which means that you can't force people
into things you have to get them to want
what you want to do as opposed to
pushing them in certain directions
despise the free lunch which is all
about the power of generosity you know
you you don't want to like always be
looking for things on the cheat you
don't want to accept things that are
free you want to pay for things and you
want to be generous with your time and
your money and your energy i mean i
could go on and on there's a core maybe
a third
that are that are kind of a little bit
hardcore and a little bit
well definitely manipulative but it's
not the majority of laws
which ones are your favorite
well law number one i have a little i
have a kind of a personal relationship
for for several reasons called never
outshine the master
and the idea is that if you enter your
the work world and you try so hard to
please and impress the boss
which is a very common thing that we do
they might end up feeling that you're
did you think that they're better than
they are you might inadvertently
outshine them and make them feel
insecure
and once you do that they're never going
to tell you that that's what you've done
they're going to fire you and you'll
never really understand why and it's
very painful
and i've had that happen to me i could
think at least three times i can recall
one very very most emotional one of all
where i was hired on the television show
to do the research and find the stories
and by far i was the most successful
researcher there
but i was making many too many people
above me feeling insecure like they
weren't getting credit for things and
they started making my life miserable
and they fired me
and i couldn't figure out why you know
like i produced i had the best record of
all why would you fire someone like that
well ego matters more than results in a
lot of a lot of places you know a lot of
work worlds and so um
and and the reason
i i like that story so much is i had
heard
somebody told me a story before all this
had happened
about louis xiv the great french king of
the 17th century
and how he had a finance minister named
nicholas fukay
who threw the most lavish party in honor
of louis the king so that he could
ingratiate himself into the king's favor
and maybe be not be nominated as prime
minister
and the party was so memorable people
wrote about it years later it had
fireworks it had plays it was i visited
the chateau where it happened it was
just the most probably the most
magnificent party ever thrown in the
history of mankind
and everyone was like telling nicholas
this is great this is wonderful well the
next day he was thrown in prison and he
spent the rest of his life in prison he
had outshone the king and i remember
that story years later when it happened
to me and i go
this there's something true there
there's something elemental about human
psychology
and years later when i was pitching
first pitched the idea to the man who
produced the 48 laws of power i started
with that story
and i told him
this happened 500 years ago when people
were wearing powdered wigs and all these
elaborate costumes but the world hasn't
changed it's the same dynamic no matter
where you are so that personally is kind
of maybe one of my favorite laws and
there are others that that stands out
that sounds extremely frustrating it
sounds like you wouldn't want your
company to
to grow really if your ego is above good
work
but isn't that pretty common haven't you
encountered that as well
i mean
yeah i mean
um the thing that people make a mistake
about i i don't know if you agree with
me here but
is that you think that the person above
you your boss
who seems he or she seems so powerful in
control
you don't realize that they have
insecurities that they have an ego that
they have weaknesses and vulnerabilities
and you assume that if you say something
that might be a little bit ambiguous
they'll laugh it off because they're so
powerful they don't care about me or
what i say but the truth is
the higher up you go in in a hierarchy
the more insecure you become
the more you're worried about whether
people really truly respect you you know
whether you people really are truly
admiring you whether you have their
attention or not and so powerful people
often have more insecurities than those
on the bottom of the scale and you go
into the work world
not thinking of the egos
of powerful people but it's it it's very
evident and it can cause you a lot of
problems
okay that makes sense and that might be
because people at the top have more to
lose potentially
that could play into it maybe
very much so that's very true
okay
okay your your book on seduction
so that's a bit
is there an overlap between that and
power
and what do you define as seduction
exactly
well there is an overlap so there are
several
chapters in the 48 laws that have to do
directly with seduction i tell seduction
stories there's one law in particular
you can use absence to create honor and
respect
and it's basically how you need to
occasionally absent yourself from other
people to get them to fantasize and
think about you and that your absence
can often be more powerful than your
presence you can be too much in people's
face and they start to see you too
familiar and they disrespect you whereas
if you step away and they don't see you
for a few days they start wondering
about you and it seems very powerful
well i consider
i say in the modern world that you can't
be too forceful and direct too brutish
or people are going to turn against you
it looks ugly so the the game of power
is to always appear to be a paragon of
virtue as they do in hollywood but to
actually be aware of the hardcore games
going on and to occasionally play them
yourself
and seduction is the ultimate form of
this power it's what napoleon bonaparte
said putting your iron fist inside a
velvet glove so when people feel your
hand on them it feels so soft and
velvety but actually it's very firm and
it's pushing people in the direction you
want so this is kind of a soft power and
seduction is by far the ultimate form of
this because what you're doing is
you're creating pleasure for people
you're giving them kind of what they
want what they secretly desire and not
many of us have enough pleasure in this
life in fact it's something that i think
all of us lack we wish we had more of it
because we're so stressed and we work
way too hard
somebody who comes into your life
and gives you something that you don't
have gives you an experience that's
different that's exciting that's
seductive and alluring
you your guard comes down your defenses
go down
normally we're very resistant people
we're very defensive but when somebody
does something that gives us that
pleasurable moment our walls come down
we started losing some of that
defensiveness and now we're open to
other things that they can do or say to
us and they have a power over us that
they wouldn't have if they were so
obvious and tried to make us do
something and so i thought seduction
is the ultimate form of power in the
modern world
and what i wanted to do in the art of
seduction was get beyond just simple
sexual seductions
you know i've certainly described
seductions between men and women gay
lesbian they even have a trans seduction
in there for sure there's the sexual
aspect but i also talk about social
seductions where you're seducing people
in the work world
there's no sex involved i talk about
political seductions i talk about
marketing seductions
what is the psychology that ties all of
this together what is it about us human
animals that make us so vulnerable and
so open to this process of seduction so
that's sort of why i wrote the book
that's very cool do you think people who
end up seducing you in some way so
giving you some pleasure that you want
and then you open up
can that be carried out for a very long
time or do you think that's kind of
fleeting and it gets burnt up eventually
or is there a relationship you can have
where that can just continue or ideally
both parties can do that for a very long
time
well you know a lot of people have come
to me unfortunately they come to me for
advice on their romantic relationships
unfortunately i can't imagine why
i'm not i don't consider myself an
expert on that the people who know more
than i do but the number one complaint i
get i hear i hear it more often from
women but i also hear from men
it's not that the man
keeps seducing me day in and day out
but that he stopped he started taking me
for granted he's become so familiar in
the beginning he started taking me out
to to movies he took just exotic places
great restaurants he dressed well you
know he was kind of
doing things that that were very
exciting and now six months into the
relationship he doesn't do any more he
doesn't put any effort into it he's
stopped seducing me in some way he's
become too familiar and it could be he
or she excuse my use of only that
pronoun
and so the idea was and i wrote about
this in the art of seduction i think
it's
chapter 24
is that you want to keep seducing the
person that you're in a relationship
with you can't do it with the same
intensity or get tiring for both of you
right because we do want to settle into
a relationship we do want a degree of
familiarity with the other person we do
want to feel comfortable but upon
occasion you have to go back to those
original moments that sparked your
desire for the other person that made
that connection so electrifying between
and you need to revive it and you need
to do some of the things that you did
before you know whatever that is
surprise them with with a gift that that
says something personal about them or
take them to some place that they're not
expecting to keep surprising them
because once the mystery is gone once
people are so familiar to you there's
something that's lost in there you know
and so it's not that you're
constantly seducing them i don't think
that's even possible
it's that you don't lose the sense of
the fact that you have to
think about the other person in their
spirit and do things that continually
surprise and excite them i don't think
there's anything
amoral or wrong about that i think it's
very healthy
no for somebody who doesn't give
advice about
seduction that sounds that sounds pretty
like pretty good advice
uh i also suppose that when people get
into a relationship the seduction part
is the first part because as soon as
you're in
a relationship and it's stable you're
not necessarily seducing anymore right
because seduction would occur
before you actually get that person
right
yes
yeah and a lot of people what happens is
um
you know in the in the first part of the
book i have the nine types of seducers
and i'm trying to tell you that you're
going to be one of these types
you know there's the siren the rape the
charmer the natural the dandy the
charismatic etc etc what's the dandy
the dandy is a person who has a kind of
androgynous edge to them
it's a man who has a slight feminine
edge it doesn't seem make him seem
you know gay or whatever if if he is
straight it just is intriguing you think
of like a mick jagger or a rock star
like
david bowie it kind of adds to their
romantic allure
and there is a slight bisexual element
to that no doubt and in a woman it's a
slight sort of masculine edge like a
marlena dietrich or a madonna and that
slight edge of masculinity doesn't put
men off it excites them and i explain
why in that chapter so that's the dandy
um i can't remember why i'm talking
about this i had a reason behind it what
was your question before do you remember
i can't remember my question before but
i have a new question anyway marilyn
monroe does she fall under the siren
most definitely she's like there are two
icons for for the siren which is the
first type that i talk about because
it's the oldest seductive type in
history
it goes back to ancient greece the the
sirens themselves in the myth
um cleopatra is the first icon
and then marilyn monroe is the second
and the reason is
is that the siren has a kind of a
theatrical edge to her it's always a
woman in this case all the other types
except the rake rakes are only men all
the other types can be either gender but
the siren is a woman who exudes this
kind of natural sexuality in everything
she does right she doesn't have to come
on overtly but it's in her glances it's
in her voice it's in her the way she
moves her body and marilyn monroe was
the quintessence of this
and part of it comes from her from her
story she was an orphan
right she had a very tough childhood
and her whole life was about the fact
that she felt abandoned that she never
had the love of a parent in her life
and it was very real
and so her desire was to get love from
everybody she came upon and she learned
early on
that by wearing a certain kind of
sweater she could excitement and and get
attention from them and then she learned
when she became an actress to kind of
make love to the camera to kind of look
at the camera in a way that wasn't
obvious but it kind of reaped some sort
of animal sexuality and it was very very
seductive it made her you know the
quintessence
of of beauty and seduction of her time
and so yeah she she's definitely one of
the icons of that for sure you talked
about the rake can you describe the rake
yeah i mean i was a rake uh i'm what you
call a reformed rake so i can speak from
experience on that
and basically my years of being raped
were in my twenties and pretty much
early thirties and then it was been
since i stopped but the rake
is a man
who has an intense interest in women
he understands them deeply he's obsessed
with women and perhaps it comes from
something relationship going with his
mother you know we can analyze that as
well but he has this obsessive interest
in them he understands their spirit he
finds it very exciting to be around them
but one woman can never satisfy him the
only way he can get satisfaction is by
constantly having new women in his life
that's how he that's how he satisfies
this hunger because the moment that a
woman becomes familiar
it kind of loses the edge that he wants
he's kind of like a hunter he loves the
process of hunting the woman of of
seducing her of getting her to fall for
him and in those first few weeks he
showers her with attention that's his
power he love bombs them he's so
he's so excited about their world he
gives them gifts that show he's thinking
about them he takes them to exciting
places it's
irresistible right
and um but the thing is it can't last
because he has to continually spread
spread the well he has to continually
find new people to conquer
and i i i in the book i kind of um
profile some of the greatest rakes who
ever lived
and one of them
is the is the great classic hollywood
actor errol flynn
um errol flynn was this devilishly
handsome man that didn't hurt but he was
also
in the end people claimed that he had
seduced or slept with about 3 000 women
and um and he died when he was 51 52
from alcoholism and so i went when i
wrote the book i kind of did the math on
that
and the math was rather insane it was
like at some point he had to be seducing
a new woman every other day something
like that
and
i was trying to figure out what was his
secret
what made him so insanely seductive to
women of all types actresses waitresses
you name it
of course being errol flynn and having
his reputation helped but he also had a
devilish edge that kind of scared a lot
of women
but i read in one book
that just being around he was so
comfortable with himself
he was so
non-defensive he was like an animal that
was completely comfortable in his body
and it was it made the woman completely
relaxed
this one woman said yeah
i felt like i had drunk a couple of
martinis and i hadn't just by being
around him
you know and so the rake has this kind
of undefensive quality he's like this
natural animal that exudes this energy
kind of like how the siren is
so that's sort of what a rake is
that was awesome
okay
cool okay so i was going to ask what the
equivalent of that was for a woman but
you're saying the siren kind of
yes um yeah definitely the siren i mean
you can't really have a male siren and
you really can't have a female rape
i mean um
i do profile in the in the in that
section
probably the greatest lesbian seductress
who ever lived natalie barney who was
kind of a poet and writer in the early
20th century
and she was the closest equivalent i
could come to a female rate
because um she was seducing women left
right and center and she had a little
bit of that presence but normally it's
something that's pretty specific to men
and women
okay
that description was amazing can i get
you to do one more
that was amazing
okay
yeah and another um i guess
seductive type
you want me to list what the other ones
are yeah yeah
that was too cool we need to do more
oh well that was the the dandy i already
mentioned the natural which is the one
who's kind of like a child
then there's the coquette
blows hot and cold
very very powerful seductress
um there's the charmer who's very good
at sort of social seductions
there's the star
the person who kind of exudes kind of
like a like a film star presence that
makes everyone project their fantasies
onto him or her and there's the
charismatic somebody who just has that
natural charisma i can't think if i'm
leaving somebody oh the ideal lover
that those those the other seven types
so you choose whichever one you want
okay
what you said there was one where you
project your ideal lover on them
well
the star
is is sort of this person i use as the
example um the woman is marlena dietrich
and the man
who's john f kennedy excuse me
president john f kennedy and what it is
is they've learned the hollywood
technique and for marlena dietrich it
was clearly you know a film thing that
she learned was you have a kind of
blankness to you
you're not too obvious in what you say
and what you do you're not overtly this
way or that way you have a kind of an
emptiness to your face to your blankness
to how you move
and you allow people you don't talk too
much and you allow people to project
onto you their fantasies they see into
you what they want to see into you
whereas if you kind of
say who you are and you're put too
direct they have they have a mysterious
error about them
and john f kennedy
he was obsessed with hollywood something
people don't understand would know very
well he was obsessed with hollywood he
was obsessed with film stars and his
favorite film star from the classic age
of hollywood was montgomery cliff
very handsome young man from the late
40s early 50s and he modeled his whole
persona after montgomery clift that kind
of silent machismo that he exuded that
kind of certain look in his eye that
montgomery clift had
and
it was immensely powerful as we saw in
the election in 1960 where so many
people saw into him what they wanted to
see you know and he disguised the
reality he disguised the reality that he
was actually
a man in his 40s who was physically and
almost crippled he had all of these
illnesses he could his back was
incredible pain but he was able to
disguise all of it and project this
other image so these are the two people
that i chose to to kind of illustrate
that
wow
and then yeah i'm sorry go ahead no no
you go ahead
well you're kind of like a blank screen
onto which people can see what they want
to see and there's a way to do that i
kind of describe in that chapter how you
can do that
can you describe how you can do that
well i understand michael i've written
seven books and i can't remember it all
of the details
um
you know like so for someone like
marlena dietrich
she would dress in a certain way
where it seemed kind of ambiguous and
you didn't know what she was doing or
what it meant she would wear for
instance she was also a dandy she would
wear for instance a man's tailored suit
right
and um but she would do it in a way the
way she hold her cigarette the way she
walked down the stairs
where you thought she was there was
something going on
she had like this added presence but she
couldn't figure out what it was because
she didn't say or do anything directly
she didn't purposely demonstrate why she
was wearing that or or reveal you know
something by the way she walked it was
just non-verbal there was something
about her in air
and she learned
in front of the camera if you've ever
acted before you understand
that quietness is much more powerful
than noise
if your face is quiet
you're able and your whole body is quiet
and your spirit is quiet you attract the
camera you attract attention it looks
powerful
in theater if there are like five actors
on the stage the man or woman who stands
with dignity who's calm who doesn't say
anything but has this presence that's
where your eye goes to and the camera
knows this
so that kind of blankness where you
allow people to see into you what they
want is what the camera loves and any
actor kind of learns that
i mean i i direct the listener here to
go and read the chapter on the star
because there's more kind of practical
advice in there if that's what you want
each each of the each of the categories
there's a lot of advice about because
the idea is michaela is
you have one of these qualities in you
it's natural to you you're kind of born
with it i don't care who you are or how
what your looks are or whatever you have
one of these qualities because seduction
isn't about beauty it's about a kind of
understanding human psychology
and if you're too obvious in your
seductive techniques if you've read
robert books the art of seduction and
you try to apply a b and c to a man or a
woman it's not good it's going to fail
because it looks too cold and
calculating
but if you see this natural quality in
you if you know that you're a coquette
by nature somebody who blows hot and
cold and you know how to bring it out
and make it more conscious and aware and
a little more
put more emphasis on it
you're seducing without appearing
unnatural you're seducing without
appearing like it's forced it just comes
from your personality and that kind of
makes it doubly effective
that's interesting
i wonder if
at some point my dad has all these
personality scales with a big five i
wonder if you could
figure out what kind of personality each
of these types has because there must be
similarities is it do you think it's
based on personality
what these nine types yeah it's based on
a kind of energy that goes that predates
that it's almost like a jungian i know
your father's heavily into you
into these kind of archetypes
that human the humans kind of fall into
right
and it's almost like an energy that you
have
and you know somebody like
the siren there might be a genetic
component to a woman who has that
but also for the siren the rake i do
believe that there's something in the
relationship to the father and the
mother kind of steers people in the
direction
you know there's the jungian concept of
the animos and the anima
the anima the man the animals for the
woman it's the internalized image of
your mother if you're a man inside of
you and it becomes the kind of woman
you're always looking for or the
internalized image of your father
becomes your animus and has a heavy
influence on all the partners that you
end up choosing so there's a level that
goes very deep inside of our nature
either early childhood or even genetic
that kind of pushes us in these
directions
that is so cool
okay
i'm gonna have to figure out what i am
which yeah which one which one would you
be
i don't know
i have no idea what do you think i know
we've only been talking for half an hour
i would say either
like
possibly the siren
i can get behind that
and possibly um
charismatic you know i i'd have to know
you a little bit but that would be the
first one that i would kind of be
that i would think of would be the siren
sweet whichever one the uh
stand in room silently to attract
attention i'm not that one
oh okay then you're not the star
okay
yeah you could have a bit of the natural
in you as well i don't know we gender
have one that's predominant for me the
rape but there's also a second quality
that's always there and for me that's
sort of the natural so there might be a
second one
lurking within you as well or even a
third who knows
cool okay um you mentioned going hot and
cold does that mean just being you know
all into a relationship and then you're
angry about something what do you mean
by hot and cold
well that's the coquette
and although we traditionally associate
the coquette with women there are plenty
plenty of male coquettes out out there
and the idea is
you know how to to
be hot in other words to be excited by
that other person to send them looks
that show that you're interested in them
to do things that show that you're
interested and once they take a step
towards you
you now take a step back and you blow
kind of cold and you're not so attentive
and you don't return their texts right
away
and you don't return their phone calls
and they start wondering
he or she was really into me but now
they don't seem to be so into me is it
my fault that i do something wrong i
better try even harder to get their
attention so you chase them
and then maybe they get hot again and
they excite you because they have to
keep keep the flame flickering otherwise
it'll die out and then they step back
they blow hot and they blow cold hot and
cold hot and cold and it's
devilishly seductive
i know it's i've fallen for in my youth
as well i have a terrible weakness for
coquettish women and it can drive you
absolutely crazy because it makes you
think that something is wrong with you
and that you have to try harder to get
them and once you think that you have to
try harder to seduce them you are the
one who's completely seduced
right
so it's it's the classic hard to get but
if you're always hard to get then
nothing will happen you know how to
occasionally mix in the easy to get with
the hard to get
yeah i think i had a relationship like
that i don't think i'm a fan of that at
all
no it's not it's not a very nice quality
but it's extremely effective i'm afraid
okay okay and then last question about
this this is fascinating um the natural
you said that was your kind of backup
so what's the natural the natural the um
the icon for that was charlie chaplin
um
basically
it's a person who has retained a lot of
their childhood qualities
right and older and then the other the
female version of it is josephine baker
the great african-american dancer and
actress of the 20s and 30s and 40s
these are people
who
they don't seem infantile but they've
grown up and they've retained a lot of
the child within them
right
they seem to have that kind of impish
mischievous quality of a child they
don't seem to be trying to put something
on they're just authentically who they
are
they're naturally spontaneous they're
naturally funny sometimes they may say
something that will offend like children
will do
right but they're very charming in the
fact that they don't seem to be trying
that they're so authentic
right
and josephine baker was this amazing
dancer
um in the 20s she was also a bit of a
dandy as well she would wear she would
dress as a man
but
her dancing was so wild and so nobody
had ever seen any dancing like that
nowadays we're kind of used to it
because we see twerking and all kinds of
things on the internet but this was the
version of it in the 20s and 30s whoa
where's this woman coming from
you know only a child would be acting
like that she's so natural she's so
comfortable with herself
and and i tell the story how she learned
as a child to always kind of live inside
of her fantasy worlds that she had as a
child and kind of retain that as she got
older and so i was staying in that kind
of
child dream world fantasy world is very
seductive on other people you know and
so um
you know it the reason it's so seductive
is it doesn't seem like a put on
and someone like a charlie chaplin
was an incredibly effective seducer and
so there is an element of calculation
behind it
you kind of know that that spontaneity
that childlike quality
is very
seductive very alluring to people so
you're going to kind of
give it a little extra sometimes you're
aware of it and you kind of
you know act a little stronger in that
direction so
okay that makes sense um for people who
are having
trouble
because there are many people i would
say
probably
men in general have more trouble with
seduction than women
probably but do you have say three tips
for people who are having trouble
seducing other people
i don't have three i have two that come
to mind maybe a third will come to me in
a few minutes
and
the first one is
you have to be able to get outside of
yourself
so in this sense seducing is very
healthy it means that
normally what where a lot of men go
wrong particularly is they're thinking
about themselves all the time they're
thinking does she really like me am i
really saying the right thing am i doing
the right thing i've got to try really
hard to make sure that she actually
likes me and they're inside their own
thoughts in their own their own world
and what they need to do instead and
this applies to women as well
is get inside the other person's world
that's the key to seducing them to
understand michaela
her childhood her needs what she has and
what she lacks in life her weaknesses
her vulnerabilities what will put a
smile on her face what will excite her
and so when you get when you have that
philosophy you listen in a different way
you're listening to them with this kind
of focus where you're picking up little
cues that they say of things that excite
them or or repulse them and you're kind
of remembering them
and then later
days later you say something that
relates to something that they had
expressed and it reveals how deeply you
were listening and it's very seductive
or you give them a gift that this ta
that isn't necessarily expensive but is
tailored to something that they had said
some nuance that they had revealed in
their conversation it seems very
personal
so getting outside of yourself and
getting into the spirit of the other
person is probably the most important
thing of all
the second one which is related to the
first one is to lose your defensiveness
to lose your defensive qualities
to be open to the other person to being
vulnerable to the other person
you know a lot of people now in the
world today are very defensive and for
good reason
because our lives are so stressful we
have so many things in our face so many
people bothering us etc and we kind of
get really rigid and tight and defensive
and
you can even physically locate it in our
chest areas etc
and the idea of being vulnerable
of opening up to another person allowing
them to have power over us is actually
frightening for a lot of people
but it's it's it's unnatural it's not
human
because
we have a tremendous need to feel
vulnerable to feel open to the influence
of another person to have that
electrical current going back and forth
and it stems from our childhood where we
were so vulnerable to the spirit of our
father or our mother and it delighted us
right there was a kind of bond between
us like between a mother that transcends
you you're almost a part of her in some
way and so that need to feel connected
to feel vulnerable is very human
and what happens with a lot of people is
as they get older and they accumulate
pain and hurts from broken relationships
is they don't want to be vulnerable
anymore because they don't want to have
to go through that
but that means that the person that
broke your heart that made you
vulnerable has won has defeated you has
made you turn into something that you
don't want to become
so you have to be able to feel that you
can be vulnerable right and if you're a
seducer trying to seduce someone
revealing to that other person that you
have fallen under their spell
is almost the most seductive thing you
can do
because it's deeply deeply exciting to
feel that that other person is charmed
by us right but in order to do that you
have to be vulnerable to them so those
are the two keys if i
i could come up with a third but um
no that was good i'm kind of slowing
down here yeah no that that was really
good um i was i was quite ill for most
of my life i had autism
i was i was really really ill
and part of the way i got through that
was building up these kind of like
psychological walls
so that i couldn't feel
and then once i got healthy
i still had these walls up and it took
me a number of years to start like
shedding them and it was like it was so
absurd it was like i could feel i could
feel when they went away and i'd cry a
whole bunch and then i'd be like okay
walls are lowering walls are low
yeah it was wild
how did you how did you lower the walls
do you remember
yeah i'd connect with people
and in order you know i'd connect with
somebody and then
i'd hit a wall and be like oh i could
feel it right it was like i'm not i'm
not connecting there's some sort of
blocking and then i just kind of
it was it hurt almost but i'd relax a
little bit and be like okay you know i'm
not in the same kind of chronic ill
health problems that i was like i can
let my walls down a little bit and then
i could experience more positive emotion
more connection
but yeah i'd say a lot of people are
suffering from
from that from being hurt from
relationship problems from being ill
from being stressed sure kovid hasn't
contributed very well to that
no no no that's definitely put a damper
on people's dating habits for sure
yeah that's very valuable information
then um do you have i guess do you have
advice for people who
are kind of trapped
to try and let down some of their walls
well i think you what you said is is
very valid and very interesting it's the
fact that you could feel them rising up
you could feel yourself starting to
judge the other person
right that's sort of we disguise our own
defensiveness from to ourselves we say
it's the other person who's acting in
this way that isn't right they're being
aggressive they're bothering us etc we
blame them whereas you have to look
inward and see that maybe you were the
one that's putting up the wall not them
doing something to you you are afraid
of of being hurt and so you're finding
an excuse to kind of raise the wall you
know and you're thinking of
you're anticipating the hurt or the pain
that's going to come right and it starts
with you
and so
being aware of the fact that you are
probably
you know if you look at how you judge
other people that's a sure sign of your
defensiveness now sometimes
you're right in your judgments and you
need to be
somewhat defensive because there are
scary people in the world there are
toxic narcissists for instance there are
people who are very aggressive and
dangerous
so you can't just be open to everyone
going around you're going to really
really suffer so there's a good reason
to be a little bit defensive in this
world and i understand that but the
point where it becomes painful and
unproductive is in your personal
intimate relationships
so you know you you carry over your your
fear of people into these personal
relationships and you're not even aware
of it happening because you think it
comes from them that's really from your
own defensiveness and you have to be
aware of the fact
that you're not
that you're paying a price for that
you're not being a complete human being
because
we are more than anything we're not
these intellectual rational animals
we're emotional animals
emotions dominate our behavior emotions
dominate our reactions to the world they
are much more powerful than thoughts
where are these emotional animals
and to not ex experience the full range
of emotion to not experience the full
range of love and as well as depression
and hurt is to be part half human right
and so you're really in the end hurting
yourself
you're not protecting yourself you're
hurting yourself and i repeat once again
that it's very important to um be able
to detect the toxic people out there and
that was the subject of my last book the
laws of human nature
but you can't you have to be at some
point not be paranoid and realize that
not everybody is like that and that you
have to kind of
let yourself be vulnerable so that you
can experience sometimes experiencing
pain and depression is important and
necessary because part of growth is part
of being a human being you know we all
go through those periods i go through
them myself but to try and repress that
and to make everything kind of even
where you're not experiencing joy or
pain
is i think to stifle your your your
your human qualities
yes
that was great
have you had negative feedback from any
of the books you've written
of course
i mean um
mostly the first two books because
they're the the darkest the most devious
of my books if you want to say put it
that way
and um
you know
people were saying that um i was
promoting kind of
almost rape culture or something that
and it wasn't my intention at all and
most people who like sometimes i get um
emails i've gotten a lot of emails from
women who say
i think this man this boyfriend and my
former boyfriend read your book
and he did some really awful things to
me
and i and i feel very bad about that you
know it's not the majority it's
occasional and sometimes i've tried to
advise them about how you know what how
to respond then how to feel
afterwards
so i get some negative feedback from
that and from the 48 laws
but most of it is
i'm not personally i mean
i don't know if people will believe it
but i'm not personally
a devious evil machiavellian character
i'm more kind of naive and innocent kind
of stupid in some ways
and when i entered the work world i was
making all kinds of mistakes like i
mentioned earlier in hollywood i
outshone the master etc etc and so i
wrote the 48 laws of power and the art
of seduction from the point of view of
people who are not good at the game who
need to understand how it works so that
they can defend themselves so they can
use some of these laws of power as well
in the world
um but yeah i still get this criticism
and i understand where it's coming from
okay that makes sense well
robert greene
that was amazing thank you so much oh
that was thank you i really i really
enjoyed it yeah i wanted to hear i
wanted to hear more of your stories but
we'll maybe do that another time we
should do that another time
we should do that another time for sure
and i think i'll hook you up with my dad
i think you guys would have a great
conversation
so we shared we share some similar
interests you know um i mean i've read
his books and i know we're both
interested in young yeah and we're both
very much interested in ancient cultures
and ancient civilizations history
um and a few other similar interests but
that would be fun that would be fun i
have here i'm gonna link this below
i have this here
yeah so that's gonna be linked below
when is it out
it's out october 12th
okay yeah
and basically what it is is um
it's
extracts and from podcasts and from my
books and from things i've written over
the course of my of the 25 years that
i've been writing
and each day is kind of a meditation on
a specific subject
and it's basically i'm trying to help
you gain a more realistic attitude
towards life
so that you don't so that you understand
people on a deeper level and then you
understand yourself on a deeper level
and it's kind of structured to take you
through the whole year
focusing on your career focusing on
power games focusing on seduction and
influence and then finally focusing on
human nature and the last month there
are extracts from the new book that i'm
working on called the law of the sublime
so there's some original material in
there but it's basically a book to make
you think every day and kind of absorb
ideas that are scattered throughout six
of my other books
that's so cool
wow okay yeah so it's dated
you can start in yeah this is great what
the mentor needs how to learn quickly
and deeply
understand how the brain works okay well
thank you very much for the book thank
you very much for coming on that was a
very entertaining podcast i'm glad i'm
glad you liked it thank you i enjoyed it
myself i found it very entertaining as
well
good
okay wow and that's that's clint
eastwood staring at me i've been kind of
intimidated by that gun being pointed at
me but
yeah you should are marlin brando over
there
yeah i recognize that johnny cash
yes i know yeah
your icons
yeah role models yeah exactly marilyn
monroe is around here too but she's not
in this one okay okay very good
okay well thanks for coming on that was
fun
thank you so much mikayla my pleasure i
really enjoyed it
you